every time sean cotton will see me in
that damn email he'll take it
and
he was trying to be funny at first but
he didn't know he was helping me
he like
yeah rapper that uh bfb rapper
girlfriend gives him chlamydia
right just don't know [ __ ] free promo
you must not know i i got no shame in my
game yeah [ __ ] what i'm living like
this yeah
all it is is a by the way
all it is
is a penicillin shot to the ass and
three days on the bench and you're back
and you're back back over here slugging
that and you're back
you gotta sit on that bench for three
days you feel me i still love my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] gave me gonorrhea but i still
love her that was the line was that's
that [ __ ] like
yeah that [ __ ] every since then it was
on
so
every time i would put out a single
he would he would throw that in there
girl gives
you feel me [ __ ] getting mad at
this right right right right my [ __ ]
like bro why the [ __ ] you keep doing
that whole ass [ __ ] bro relax damn see
the vision i see the vision like it's
free promotion come on people are paying
for that kind of promotion
you getting it for free
come on man bro they don't under bro
they don't see this internet [ __ ] i see
that's where i'm at where i'm at right
now ain't got no shame my [ __ ]
i ain't got no shame and it's the truth
i ain't no no six nine [ __ ] no you ain't
do it yeah for sure you just that what
he was doing was a lie that wasn't him
you being you unapologetically caught an
std for my [ __ ] and i still love her
you feel me that actually happened i'm
really living like that oh facts okay